September 2011 will mark four years since the release of the Foo Fighters' last release...
..."Echo, Silence, Patience and Grace".
And now, Foo fans have reason for celebration.
Singer - songwriter Dave Grohl and crew tweeted about their time in the recording studio,...
...saying, quote, "Ladies and gentlemen, we are officially done. Champagne anyone?", end quote.
Foo Fighters' sound has evolved as Dave has learned to trust his singing voice.
In an interview shortly before the release of their last album,...
...Grohl told Artisan News that just about anything could now be considered a Foo Fighters tune.
Whether it's an accordion, a mandolin and an acoustic guitar,...
...or four people with electric guitars, it's just Foo Fighters, you know.
And I think that's the idea, is just get to the point where, you know, it's...
...anything could be a Foo Fighters song, you know.
There has been no release date but the Foos are already soliciting talent for someone to direct their new video.
Go to foofighters.com for more details.